the open they want to be beaten down by
a bunch of older women for my body bella
thorne is receiving massive support from
celebs after her tearful reaction to
Whoopi Goldberg's comments on the view
you cannot be surprised that someone has
hacked you especially if you have stuff
on your phone I'm not gonna lie I want
to say that I feel pretty disgusting you
know I feel pretty disgusting won't be
knowing everyone's ceiling you know
Bella shared support from celebs like
zendaya Lucy Hale Lily Rose depth dove
Cameron and Tyler Posey as well as
praising Sharon Osbourne's comments on
the talk that people ought to learn from
Bella because the thing is you can't
roll the dice with something like this
you never can because they will put it
out I like down to her she's brave she's
done the right thing and other people
you never ever want to be blackmailed
never here's the backstory Bella Thorne
released nude photos of herself in order
to take her power back after an alleged
hacker got a hold of that but on
Tuesday's episode of the view Whoopi
wasn't exactly on Bella's side if you're
famous I don't care how old you are you
don't take nude pictures of yourself
once you take that picture it goes into
the cloud and it's available to any
hacker who wants it and if you don't
know that in 2019 but this is an issue
you you I'm sorry your age does not you
don't get to do that
Bella spoke out in a series of emotional
Instagram stories Tuesday after the
episode aired saying she was canceling
her scheduled appearance on the show I
just want to say that me watching this
interview made me feel really bad about
myself and I hope you're happy I really
do I really hope yourself happy because
I can only imagine all of the kid to
have their release and then they come in
suicide